i love love okay
and there's a story uh
that you fell in love with the stripper
i mean you have to tell the story so how
did you fall in love
with somebody not there's anything wrong
with that profession but it's it's it's
romantic it's like a true romance by the
way a great movie it is a great bill
it's truly a great film and even even
brad pitt um who makes a brief
appearance is genius there's so much
good acting there anyway uh so tell me
that love story all right so you know
what uh like i said i get
from my dad i get that fear of being
abandoned you know i lied to my wife for
nine years until she leaves and
i was in charleston south carolina and
what happened was
i noticed that susan uh
she was not coming to bed like you know
she used to and she'd stay up all night
long and sometimes she'd go and
be gone a few hours and everything else
and i'm like well something's going on
and i'd pass by her her computer and she
would minimize the screens and i'm like
well
got to figure out what that was going on
so
put a key logger on her system as any
uh anybody should in their relationship
well absolutely because you trust them
you know yeah
why not you should be tracking all their
movements all their exactly exactly like
i said i was the control freak too
so um
found out she'd been cheating on me and
she was um here you go they had a reason
bad reason i justified
so i found out she was cheating on me
she was asleep when i found it out and i
sat there looking at and i was like well
[ __ ]
so got up walked in the bedroom opened
up the wardrobe got a suitcase out
started putting her clothes in it and
she wakes up she's like where are you
going i'm like i'm not you are
well
my my bravado disappeared pretty quickly
i uh
took about a week
of both of us crying and arguing
and everything else and she she finally
left
and uh
i went through this depression i went uh
i was in charleston south south carolina
i would just walk around the house kind
of stumbling into daze
realized i was getting suicidal
and uh was smart enough to do something
about it and picked up the phone book
and uh that's where there's always this
sense of humor so i picked up a phone
book i'm going through the yellow pages
i'm like psychologist criminal
psychologist because i need that
[Laughter]
called this psychologist crying to her i
mean crying on the phone told her
everything i'm this criminal this is
what's happened she's like come in now
it's like go in spill my guts and uh
saw her for about four months and i joke
about but it's true she she was trying
to get me to stop breaking the law
and to go into real estate and i
remember telling her is there a
difference
she was like yes there's a difference
so i saw her for about four months i was
i was 34.
i didn't start drinking until i was 34.
i'd never done drugs or anything else
like that because my mom was an addict
as well
so i i was this guy i always wanted to
be in control didn't want to
you know
lose control of myself and uh had never
been to strip club
so one night i was getting lonely so i
walked into the strip club actually i
was researched this strip club and it
was uh joe's roundup
in charleston south carolina
joe's roundup a little bitty hole in the
wall stuff i was yeah real classy so i
walked in
and i'm literally that guy man
that fell in love with the first the
first stripper that he sees
she walks by i'm like
that one
so i didn't know i didn't know the strip
club game again criminal naive as hell
so uh
belly up at the bar
order the beer i'm sitting there
drinking it
she comes over to me
and we start talking and she's like
would you like to get a bottle of
champagne i was like
does that mean going in back or what
she's like well yeah you need to do
bottles going back and i was like sure
let's buy a bottle of champagne 400
bottle of corvale
like all right then again that bravado
disappears pretty quickly i get back
there and we talk
for two hours and you know nowadays i
don't understand that most men who go to
strip clubs
the strippers are their therapist most
the time all right so i'm sitting there
talking we're talking of course she's
she's sizing me up she's looking at the
watch she's like what kind of car you
drive
you know everything else and i'm like
telling her i'm talking and so at the
end of the night i'm like
really nice me and she's like it's so
nice meeting you too
so i leave
she you guys just talked and just talked
and there's no damn feeling of love and
all that yeah so just talk just you know
got along pretty good i'm like
i like her i like her
so
come back in a week later walk in and uh
call her over and i was like look i said
i'm not uh i said it was my first time
to strip club i said don't know yeah i
like you i'd like to tell you more would
you like to go out to dinner
and she was like
yeah i was like where would you like to
go so she says rude to john and i was
like don't know what it is that's where
we'll go so i go back and i was uh i had
a theater buddy at that point in time
because i was trying to get my life yeah
i tried to get my life together uh jc
was his name and i was like i got a date
he's like he got a date i was like yeah
man i got a date and he's like
okay where are you going and i was like
rude john and he's like take your wallet
i'm like yeah he's like take your wallet
that's like all right
so uh
we start
you know doing the the lunch and the
dinner thing and uh
i get to where i really like her she's
uh
i was 34 she was 23
and uh got along really well listen you
know had common interest in music and
arts and stuff like that she had i mean
a stereotypical she was she had
graduated college
with a degree
in religious studies
wow yeah
so i was like all right
so um so yeah you just fell in love yeah
we we got along really well really well
so i ended up moving her in with me
she hadn't quit her job
and uh
what was happening was she's working
weekends and
you know the club would close at three
or four
she wouldn't come home until 10 or 11 in
the morning and most the time it would
be a phone call
saying come and pick me up i can't drive
home
and
then i'd never use drugs had never been
around my mom valium and pot and things
like that but as far as interacting with
her i've never done anything like that
by this point of time i'm kind of
getting head over heels with her i've
moved around with everything and
i had never i was 34 i'd never went
through a woman's purse in my entire
life
and uh so she comes in
passes out
and i'm like i gotta know what the
[ __ ] going on
and uh
went over and went through her purse
found cocaine
and you know the straw cut off straws
and all that stuff and i'm like
broke my heart i just sat there and
started crying
got online and uh i'm the guy that can
find information so i started looking
for forums on strip clubs
found a forum
i found that one found where it was
talking about her
prostituting herself
to support the habit
and uh
that got me mad that got me talking
about everything she was doing to uh
to do that and that broke your heart
there oh man
yeah
so uh
went like i could i didn't have the
heart to tell her that i knew she was
prostitute
but i i went to and i was like she was
waking up and i was like look i found
this in your purse
i can't have that and she's like well
you think i'm prostituting i was like no
no i don't think that i knew it but i
didn't mention it to her
and
i was like i can't have that well i
don't do that it's just a one-time thing
i was like all right
so um she went back to work
and continued to do it for a couple more
weeks and then finally i was like i
can't
so i picked her up one morning as like
she was she was
couldn't drive home
before i picked her up i'd written her a
note left it on the pillow
so i brought her home tucked her in the
bed and
told her i'd be back that night told her
she had a letter when she woke up i woke
up and the letter was basically uh you
know i love you
if you can't stop this
don't be here when i get back
and
i went to columbia that day
came back that night
and uh
she'd quit her job
and she quit drugs that night
really quit him
and
i got it in my head
that i needed to do whatever i needed to
do
to make sure she didn't go back to that
that became uh
that to me because of my background that
meant spending a lot of money and
so every night was you know three to six
hundred dollars for dinner it was uh
thousand dollar shoes every week
two thousand dollar purse every week all
that i had most of my money laundered
out to uh
to estonia
and uh elizabeth at the same time
she had
she quit
but uh
she didn't want me to go anywhere
all right she wanted me there all the
time i guess that was that connection
you know she i guess she was scared she
might go back to something
so
shadow crew
gets busted i start i go through
basically all my us funds
can't get anything from overseas shadow
crew gets busted october i can't go into
committing tax fraud because season's
over
can't go back into credit fraud because
shadow crew's been busted i don't know
who to trust online
i'm left with running counterfeit
cashiers checks to get money in trying
to make it until you know
i can start back with some other fraud
and uh lying to her the entire time
she knows about none of this no no
none of it
and she's got she thinks i've got a
shitload of money and uh
she's got expensive tastes
so
um and at the same time
she couldn't be intimate
i mean
the girl loved me i i that's the first
time i've really said that
so there's deep love there both ways
yeah
yeah
things we do
so uh
she she couldn't be intimate unless she
was stone cold drunk
i mean just [ __ ] stones go drunk
and i you know i said i didn't mind her
drinking alcohol
i'd rather have that than cocaine
so
uh that was the intimacy there and i
kept i had this
i kept thinking if i continued to invest
that it would work out
you know that uh just keep
going she'll be all right
we'll be all right
and what happens is
like i said she thought i had money she
thought i had money
she wanted a couple of tiffany
engagement rings so i i said we can get
married you know i figured marriage
showed her that i love her sure it's
going to be all right so
i was like oh let's get married she's
like well i've always wanted a tiffany
ring shot i don't have money to buy the
tiffany ring because all my money was
overseas so here i am i've defraud
since counterfeit cashiers i um
find a like a three carat ring on ebay
for 20 grand and
pay for it with a counterfeit cashier's
check
at the same time because she doesn't
want me to leave
she needs me there
typically if you're doing that type of
crime you need to be traveling
you can't do it in one central area
because you're going to be identified
pretty quickly
i knew that but i didn't have much
choice
so
start running counterfeit cashiers
checks to get the money to to live and
everything
get the uh
get the engagement ring we were
scheduled to be married
our wedding date was february 26
2005.
february 8
2005.
i'm uh
i've got a tiffany wedding band a couple
of them coming in
and i get arrested
in charleston south carolina
and
she didn't know
i told her i said i've got to go pick up
those rings she didn't she thought i was
just having them sent in
so i go get those rings and i said we'll
go out to dinner after that
and
i left at like 8 o'clock in the morning
i was arrested at uh i think 11 30
something like that
of course i wanted to call her you know
and uh the fbi got me it turns out it
was it was controlled delivery there
were like 30 agents in the parking lot
fbi got me charleston pd got me within
45 minutes the secret service comes in
takes over that investigation they knew
exactly who they had
along about seven o'clock at night
they're like we want to search your
house
and i was like look i'll sign off on the
search if you let me go with you so i
can see her
and uh
they were like okay so i got to see my
phone at that point i had like 140 calls
that she where she'd been trying to call
that time just way yeah
and uh
so they load me up in hell i mean you
talk about 10 12 cars
you know 40 agents everything else she's
got a dog at that point i'm scared
they're going to shoot the dog and uh
it was dark
and they had me walk up and they're all
behind me
i knock on the door and tell her the
police are there and she needs to put
the dog up
so she does and uh
they come in and just start ransacking
them put me in cuffs set me down start
berating her with questions she had no
idea what the hell was going on were you
able to say a word or two to help her
understand yeah i was trying to tell her
and at the same time they're they're
they take a watch off her wrist they let
her keep the ring uh
they're telling her i'm this guy what's
my real name bang bang bang bang bang
across across the board she's probably
terrified oh yeah yeah
yeah and uh i tell her i was like look
they're going to arraign me tomorrow
don't come
don't come i said i'll
see what's going on but don't show up of
course she's there the next morning
her dad
and she's she's back in the back crying
they're reading off the charges i'm
under 300 000
bond
everything else and uh
that's it i
they throw me in a cell
meanwhile more charges keep coming in
you know
and uh
it's like 10 12 charges a day at that
point
and i'm trying to call her to make sure
she's all right
and
just get through
so i spent three months in jail
and during that three months she visits
twice i get like three four phone calls
to her
um
i unders looking back now i understand
why you know back then it was like i'm
the victim you know why doesn't she talk
to me but uh
you know now i understand why
hell the girl loved me too you know and
then she found out i was this piece of
[ __ ] and uh
after a week in county jail
two agents fly in from new jersey two
secret service guys pulled me out of
cell
looked at me and they were like we got
your laptop and i was like yeah and
he's like well if you got anything on
your laptop i was like yeah he's like
you're going to be charged for it that's
like i figured
and then he looks at me as like
can you do anything for us
i told my exact words were look you let
me get back with elizabeth i'll do
whatever you want me to do
and he looks at me he's like we're going
to get you out i was like all right so
they let me sit there for three months
to get a taste of it and uh
get me out my sister they have the bond
reduced to a thousand dollars
my sister pays the thousand dollar bond
by this point she's disowned me and
because i'm dating the stripper
and uh
denise bonds me out the person that i
call
immediately
is elizabeth i'm out and uh she's like
i'll be there i was like okay
so uh this uh like 11 o'clock at night
um
i'm in the parking lot of the charleston
police charleston county jail
me and a secret service agent standing
there
and elizabeth had a friend that owned a
limo company so she pulls up in a limo
gets out pops the trunk
gets these two plastic containers out
that have my clothes in them
drops them off pavement comes over hugs
me
call me later
gets in the car drives off
i'm sitting there crying like a baby
agent looks at me is that your fiance
i'm like yeah he's like i am so sorry
and i'm like yeah
i had
she sounds fascinating
yeah pull up in a limo
i had thirty dollars my name at that
point thirty dollars uh the agent had to
pay for my hotel room that first night
so he drops me off after paying for the
hotel room buy me something to eat as
soon as he drops me off i take that
thirty dollars
walk a half mile to walmart buy a
prepaid debit card so i can start back
in tax fraud
so as i get back to hotel room call
elizabeth beggar to come see me
she comes to see me and we talk most of
the night
and uh
convince her to give me a chance i tell
her that
everything's going to be all right
they're going to hire me i'm going to be
this big
consultant lies lies just so she get
back with me
and
she's like okay
and
so we moved from from charleston the
field office is in columbia south
carolina
and uh
i'm breaking the law
even before i start working with them
i'm breaking the law
and
so they've got me in the office
the field offices they got this big war
room in there i'm on a laptop outside
line
laptops hooked up to a 50-inch plasma
monitor on the wall
they've got
a desktop sitting directly next to me
outside line two secret service office
officers in the room at all times with a
south carolina law enforcement officer
my job is four to six hours a day
surfing the web
picking up targets intel teaching them
how cyber crime operates everything else
like that
for the first two weeks
they are extremely diligent
they pay attention to everything that's
going on ask questions everything else
but the problem is is that
that [ __ ] gets boring
real quick
because i'm i'm very fast online doing
that
so they're they're like what the hell is
he doing and it gets tiring looking at a
guy just doing that [ __ ]
so after two weeks they get lazy
and bored and they start
watching porn
instead of watching me
at the same time they've got a key
logger
and they've got they've got spectre pro
and camtasia key loggers and taking
snapshots of everything that i'm doing
go every night it goes on a dvd rom on a
spindle so i'm like
they're not going to go through that
[ __ ]
so i'm like [ __ ] it
start breaking all from inside secret
service offices while they're in the
room why not
that continues for 10 months
at the same time
the relationship with elizabeth fell
apart
completely fell apart
do you have an understanding of why it's
just because of the
her heart got broken because there was
lying it was the truth like she did a
lot yeah to uh sacrifice for the liver
you've got uh
you got a woman there that uh
she had even said it she was like uh
she had told one of her friends we were
out uh having dinner one night
and this is before i got arrested she
told one of her friends and i was the
only guy
that ever asked her to stop using drugs
yeah
yeah
yeah i mean i i have to say that that
part of the story is so
it's so powerful
and then that she chose to do it
and she chose to
stop
and she told me that uh
there was one instance she told me that
if she if she didn't marry me you should
never be married and
uh as far as i know she's never been
married
and so it started to fall apart there
yeah
because
i was a piece of [ __ ]
still you didn't take a step by the way
can i just say how just moving it is how
honest you are but yeah thank you thank
you for being that person
but at that time you
there's still that lying oh man yeah
yeah yeah so uh it's falling apart
she had uh she wants to start going to
strip clubs and uh
i'm like [ __ ] it why not
we'll go
so we start going to strip clubs and
she's you know she'll come back and get
wasted and we'll
have sex what have you and uh
one night
she looks at me and she was like
she was like i think it'd be funny if
you got a [ __ ] from somebody else
and uh
that got me
that got me i was like uh
to me that was the final straw right
there i was like
she doesn't care for me anymore or
anything else like that
we've been going to strip clubs
so i started dating another stripper and
uh
she knew something was going on
and uh
she looks at me one day and she's like
why don't you just tell me that it's
over and i looked at her i said it's
over
we're done
and uh
i told her i was like look i said uh
whatever you want we were renting an
apartment i was like whatever you want
in here take it
and
i said not only that but uh
i'll make sure you got money
for for several months so you're all
right
and i was like just leave me uh you know
leave my tv and leave
leave me some some plates and stuff
so i go to work that day at the secret
service
come back that night and she's taken
everything and left a picture of herself
in the bedroom on the floor i'm like
okay i guess i deserve that so
he's got i
i like her yeah
so
i i i'm giving her a thousand dollars
like every two weeks for some [ __ ] like
this and uh
it gets to the point because i'm doing
this tax fraud from inside the offices
well the debit card companies
are pinging the cards they start to
realize that hey some son of a [ __ ] is
stealing money using our debit card so
they start to shut down the cards before
i can pull cash out so i start not to
have the money to send to her and i'm
like
so i she calls and she's like look i i
have to have money
and i was like well look i'm doing what
i can
you promised money and i was like look
if you knew what i was doing to get this
money you wouldn't be asking that
and uh she's like i need money my rent's
behind by a month right now and i'm like
your rent's behind she's like yeah so
i was like okay so i pick up the phone
call the rental office and i was like
i just want to make sure that
you know i'm sorry i'm behind on the
rent for this apartment number oh no
that rent's paid up three months
it's like okay hang up call elizabeth
back i was like you're behind on the
rent and she was like yeah and i was
like
funny they just said you're up on it
three months and she gets quiet and
she's like
well you lied to me too
and i was like
you're right
i did i did that and i was like but look
i i can't do it anymore and
that's the last time i spoke to her
right there
you